[Musique]
une deuxième édition pour les halls
factory festival le coup d'envoi de la
manifestation sera donné le 18 septembre
prochain
au programme artistes de renommée
internationale ou locale mais aussi
trois créations
donc évidemment nathalie d'auxerre avec
du plâtre castrale vendredi on aura
aussi jacob desvarieux ses amis et les
musiques au pays
le samedi et on aura également une
création de clémentine de couture est
une chanteuse de deux d'opéra et de
musique classique travail race pour le
reste du g20
si à l'origine le groupe têtes raides
devait jouer sur la grande scène les
artistes ont été contraints d'annuler
ils seront remplacés par les ogres de
barback le concert se déroulera le
dimanche 20 septembre à 20 heures
je dois vraiment remercier les ogres de
barback fonte qui ont un vrai une vraie
volonté de solidarité de soutien pour le
festival qui savent le travail qui est
déployée par les organisateurs et qui
ont vraiment envie de continuer à
assaisonner leurs liens avec leur public
et donc c'est pour ça que l'on accepté
avec grand plaisir de s'adapter et de
venir au festival contexte sanitaire
oblige des dispositifs ont été mis en
place pour respecter les gestes
barrières notamment le port du masque
obligatoire ou encore un nombre de
spectateurs limiter la fallu au tout
tout tout remodeler en cas de plan donc
et et pour assurer la sécurité du public
donc il va y avoir distanciation il va y
avoir des départs cours pour que les
gens ne puissent pas se croiser il va y
avoir du nettoyage aussi sur l'ensemble
du site du festival des points de gel
hydroalcoolique pas beaucoup de mesures
concrètes
le festival se déroule du 18 au 20
septembre programme et réservations sur
eole factory festival.com